okay so in this skype makes it possible
Moby Souls head office in Berlin is
holding a face-to-face conference with
staff in Arusha Tanzania mobis all
delivers its mobile solar systems to
three African countries it's barely
keeping up with demand Thomas God shark
founded the company in 2010 to get
electricity to places not on the grid it
is fun the idea came from my co-founder
whose wife was traveling in Africa and
saw the problem most people have no
access to electric power but they do
have cell phones in addition solar
panels have become very cheap in recent
years so we added one and one and came
up with moby songs were astonished on
the company's solar systems can generate
between 80 and 200 watts of power the
least expensive costs 500 euros and can
easily charge a cell phone and provide
power for bright LED lights and a radio
customers can spread payment over three
years paying the installments from their
cell phones plus along the quantum
keinen most of our customers have no
bank account but there are mobile
payment apps they can use to send money
from A to B money application we don't
need people going around collecting
payments yet then you don't have to use
cash it's a good solution for organizing
payments easily and cheaply nookalu
someone's ear costigan cicada answers
oven in the small workshop next door
engineers are optimizing the technology
the solar controller he attract
technical data from the panel and
battery then transmits it wirelessly to
a database in Berlin any problem can be
addressed swiftly does a steer you know
this is the energy control mechanisms of
common cuts it contains a communications
module which allows us to collect all
data in real time simplifying
maintenance upgrades and customer
service quinton service 250 yah mo B Sol
is hiring both in east africa and berlin
were development production and sales
are all coordinated in german and
english and in chinese
solar panels are manufactured in China
Moses and I continent Moby Saul is
active on three continents our
manufacturing is in Germany and China
and our sales are in Africa logistics is
a challenge between the different
countries the different continents
trucks can overturn and getting enough
systems to where the customers are is a
big challenge water horse fulfills so
far the challenges paid off Moby Saul
has already provided mobile solar
systems to more than 60,000 households
in Africa and more are sure to follow